Hamilton the Broadway musical about
America's founding fathers earned over a
billion dollars in global sales becoming
the fastest turning Broadway musical
ever when Hamilton came out in 2015 the
optimistic hopeful an inclusive
portrayal of America was an immediate
hit but getting a ticket was almost
impossible seats sold for over $10,000
on the secondary market fans entered
digital lotteries and waited in endless
lines all for a chance to see this Tony
Grammy and Pulitzer Wedding play out of
the top ten highest grossing Broadway
musicals Hamilton was the quickest to
reach a billion dollars in earnings so
far it's Broadway run has made six
hundred and forty nine million dollars
with its US tour and West End production
bringing in 167 million and thirty-eight
million dollars respectively then
there's the staggering amount of money
made in publishing as well as an
expansive line of parts and dice and
since lin-manuel Miranda had a few
different revenue streams writing the
libretto the score and playing the title
role on stage he personally netted 14
million dollars Disney first revealed it
was bringing them the original stage
performance of Hamilton directed by
Thomas Kael to the big screen in October
2021 a surprise announcement changed
that entirely Hamilton will be streaming
on Disney Plus on July 3rd of this year
the decision to release the film on
Disney streaming platform puts an
additional thirty million dollars in
Miranda's pocket making him one of this
year's highest earning celebrities
miranda is a powerful voice of activism
on social media platforms and he has
donated millions to cause us to further
diversity in the arts and other
important issues
[Music]